[Music]
you'll see a pair of laughing eyes
and suddenly a sighting size
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
trap
in australia we're habitual gamblers
people will come and gamble
every day playing just push button
25 lines they're here for entertainment
the pokies in just over 50 years
they've gone from being illegal to being
everywhere
over two hundred thousand machines are
spread through our cities
suburbs and country towns
we keep playing
and we keep losing 12 billion dollars
a year sometimes i just want to reach
out to slot machine players and say wake
up why are you playing this thing it's
stealing your money
so what is it that keeps people playing
we'll go behind the bright lights
and ask is it us or the machine
you may think that people play the
pokies to win a jackpot
but your chances of winning are worse
than nearly any other form of gambling
so are poker machines delivering
something else
slot machines have been called the crack
cocaine
of gambling electronic morphine
i was in a heist for nearly 20 years
with the help of modern neuroscience and
a maths wizard
we ask have designers created
the perfect addiction machine
[Music]
even the earliest poker or slot machines
seem to exert a strange power to
separate people from their money
one armed bandits invented in the usa
by the 1930s they were banned in every
state there
except nevada
but there was one other place that
declared them legal
in 1956 new south wales
australia
[Music]
community and sporting clubs were given
the exclusive right
to operate pokies and soon they were
rolling in cash
there's dancing several nights a week
and squash
golf
[Music]
many of these clubs have evolved into
something entirely different
many casinos dotted across our suburbs
we've grown we have approximately seven
restaurants
retail conferencing and events
we do try to be a five-star venue our
furniture and fittings are all designer
and 332 gaming machines
for decades a new south wales club was
the only place in australia
you could play a poker machine and a
sydney sider
len ainsworth became one of the largest
pokey manufacturers in the world what's
the attraction of these things why do
people play them and like them
well you can win on a poker machine you
can win them
yes of course you can if you've got the
method the system uh no it's not a
matter of that
it's a case of you get back 90
of your stake on average and uh if you
uh happen to strike a um a winning run
you can be a long way in here
but of course that's the time to
withdraw so your advice to the poker
machine
player would be know when to stop know
when to stop yes
i decided on politics still working as a
psychologist
and i so enjoyed influencing
policy we'd been lobbied as members of
parliament for years by
poker machine manufacturers wanting to
bring them in
i was the government whip so i ended up
speaking on it in favor
everyone felt great relief at the state
not being broke anymore
in the 90s the floodgates opened with
poker machines going into pubs and clubs
in
every state except western australia
over time when we were playing rock and
roll around the pubs
you'd see more and more poker machines
coming into the hotels
funneling of people in to ching
chinching how much money you got to
spend today
let's have a look at it oh that's
terrific
[Applause]
rivers of money poured into state
treasuries
governments became addicted to the
revenue
we'd become a pokey nation
no one was marching in the streets
demanding the right to play poker
machines
in fact quite the opposite was the case
somewhere between three quarters and 80
percent of the population think the
pokemon sheets
need to be rained back when pokies came
in
people who were in my church who didn't
have any
addiction problems suddenly were telling
me stories
of how they were spending far too much
money
some committed crimes lost businesses
lost marriages lost homes and
i remember thinking what is this
the modern poker machines were a far cry
from the early mechanical models
transformed by the introduction of video
screens and the computer chip
the reels had become virtual keeping the
fantasy
of spinning reels but putting the odds
and a tool kit of tricks with designers
coins became notes or even cashless
tickets
they were much faster than any other
type of gambling
buttons let you bet every three seconds
up to ten dollars a spin or twelve
hundred dollars
in an hour
[Music]
in other countries such high-intensity
machines
are usually confined to casinos
here they were in the local pub
in the early 90s i would go to these big
gaming expos in las vegas
and with the australians were really the
the kings of the floor
and it was aristocrat and they really
had the presence of aristocrats because
everyone was sort of following them
around
they designed these incredibly complex
machines where you don't really know if
you're winning these multi-line machines
and what's the secret of the company's
success oh i think um
building a better mousetrap
my mum called me lucky all the time she
said i was just the luckiest person ever
when i was 18 i won 50 grand
in a scratchy thing and so that sealed
it for me i was just definitely lucky
and i bought a house and that's the
house i lost
i was really really a good mother
then the divorce happened and it was all
just
over unfortunately the pokies were there
on the weekends when i didn't have my
children
and i wasn't alone you know i could
dress up and feel like i was going out
i had cigarettes a glass of wine
i put my legs you know
there where the machine is and i thought
it was paradise
but this preoccupation took over
everything like everything
before i knew it i was sort of trapped
in there
i haven't played now for 10 years and
i run the pokies anonymous group
there's around 200 000 australians who
struggle with these machines
they're the backbone of the pokey
industry providing 60
of its profits
what's in these machines that can have
such a hold on people
the industry in australia is highly
secretive
so we visited the slot machine spiritual
home
las vegas
[Music]
tucked away in the back streets a slot
machine creator
was happy to talk i've been in the
gaming business for about 25 years
we are the creators we're kind of kids
that never grew up
i'm 55 and i play at least two hours of
xbox a day
at least
[Music]
so in this case this game that we're
seeing here
is titled super chicken for bars and
taverns
along chesapeake beach maryland and
behind very near chesapeake beach it's
kind of a rural farm area
so we came up with with an idea to
create a game based on a chicken
a super chicken it's not superman it's
not a chicken it's super chicken
and basically it's got a lot of plucking
it's got a lot of
the the bonuses are based on the
hatching of baby chicks
there needs to be something that pulls
them to the machine and that's what the
graphics are
they're animated now they'll actually
put their arms out and things and
make sounds like all these weird really
amazing sounds and
the gang will just be sitting back going
oh yeah
this is incredible
images of adventure stories like there's
the arabian
deeds there's pyramids there's you know
those
childhood stories they were so
adventurous that we read
they appealed to the child in a child
i started in australia working for
aristocrat
and yeah i ended up here in vegas three
years ago
i tend to think of the games as like
little movies
little stories because it is kind of
like a film in that you have this
you just have one scene though that kind
of plays over and over again
i really you know like a strong
character in a game a strong pair of
eyes
in that moment where you're kind of
deciding which game you're going to play
by character staring right at you might
make you
stop for just that moment
so it's like the latest and greatest
from our studio it's got a really nice
kind of australian desert iconography
and queensland blue catalogue and it's
got that
lonely man the desert road kind of vibe
to it
when i was 17 a friend of mine took me
down to the local rsl club
didn't really think anything of it i
just went in and put a couple of dollars
in and
yeah the first time i ever played them
got a feature
whenever the car comes across like that
it means that something good is going to
happen too
and then uh you hit the nitro
it comes through and smashes through the
screen
lights good everything was happy and
then
yeah the money sort of started going up
and up and up and
it's just like a do do do do do like
shouting out here that
there's money on the way
i composed music for poker machines
and did that for about five years
you want to keep the players attention
on the machine
you don't want them to become too
mindful and start
thinking about things at home and maybe
negative things are happening in their
life
obviously some people have the problems
with gambling there might be guilt
associated
with it or whatnot you could redirect
that with some positive
music that is
more of an escape for them
you know everything's in major key
so happy sounding if you lose
there'll be no sound because you don't
want to reinforce
that you've lost so there won't be a bit
barrel
the winning sounds
coins people cheering at the end
[Music]
they feel good about what they've done
and they keep plugging away
[Music]
in the 19th century russian scientist
ivan pavlov
discovered something extraordinary
if you played a metronome or bell every
time you fed a dog
before long the sound alone would make
the animal salivate
it associates reward with a particular
sound
and poker machines do exactly the same
thing
and if you look at a big poker machine
venue where there are hundreds of
machines
bells and whistles going off all the
time
and this partly explains why big venues
make much more money per machine
than smaller venues reinforcement is
almost constant
in ontario canada dr kevin harrigan
has pioneered research into our
biological responses to poker machines
he has a very nice clean heart rate so
we like that
these electrodes they're just recording
your finger sweat
which allows us to get a measure of kind
of how excited you are
[Music]
the first thing that popped out at us
was so the machine is constantly
emitting positive sounds
even when you put a 20 bill in the
machine it almost sounds like you win it
goes tada
you know incredibly you're winning
something in almost every second spin
if the manufacturer did that too much
then the manufacturer would lose money
so the question arises how do they
manage to
give so many wins and that
is through what we call losses disguised
as wins
many of your wins on modern slot
machines
are in fact net losses
so you wager a dollar and you win back
30 cents let's say
so you have a net loss of 70 cents but
the machine
celebrates that 30 cent wind with
graphics and sound
now that was a big win
[Music]
i've lost the sky says a win i've got a
nice elevated response for that
interestingly we find you get the bodily
reaction
that is telling you that you're winning
a lot
these machines work on even deeper
levels of our brain
in the 1950s american psychologist
b.f skinner observed animal behavior
to try and understand human behavior
he trained a rat to press a lever for
food pellets
if it received them at regular intervals
it would only press when hungry
but if the food was given randomly if
the rat never knew when it was coming
it would press the lever again and again
and again
it worked on pigeons and it worked on
humans too
there is a good example of how you can
move from
the the pigeon to the human case because
one of the schedules which is very
effective is a variable ratio schedule
and that is at the heart of all gambling
devices
in skinner's day rewards were decided by
where the mechanical reels stopped
but since virtual reels took over where
the reels stopped
is in the hands of designers if we took
the super chicken game as the player
will see it
and superimpose the math over it
this is actually the game being played
i could remove the graphics remove the
sound
and allow a player to play an excel
spreadsheet and the outcome will be the
same
except it's not going to be fun we don't
share math
the heart of a game is math and that's
the only that's our product
[Music]
no matter what your job is whether it be
designing slot machines or
cutting grass i really think you should
take pride in what you do and do the
best job possible
[Music]
my name is mike shackleford but i'm more
commonly known as the wizard of odds
the big slot machine companies have big
math departments
there's a very small number of people
that freelance like me
i am looking at a game that i titled
golden chariots
it's my understanding that marcus the
client reskinned it to a game
called super chicken
but the theme of the game
[Music]
is not important to me it's the actual
math and the design of the game
here's the real strips uh the way
it works is the game will pick a random
number from 1 to 128 for each reel
there's 128 to the fifth power
ways that the reels could stop let's
say that the random number for real 2
is 65 then it will stop
with the bonus symbol in the middle with
a harp above it
and a helmet below it if you get at
least
three bonus symbols you're gonna win
free spins
[Music]
the mathematician rewards the player
enough to keep them playing
while making sure the machine comes out
ahead
according to a calculation called the
return percentage
slot machines are set to only return
about 90 percent of your money
so ever with every bet you make you're
giving 10 percent to the house which
which is a lot
and of course in the short run anything
could happen you could lose a lot more
or you could win a lot more but the way
the laws of mathematics
are over the long run the closer it will
get to this
return percentage how do slot machines
compared to other forms of gambling
other forms generally are much better
the best bets in the casino are craps
blackjack and video poker the house take
on most casino games is an average
of one to two percent but on poker
machines
it's around 10 to 13
when i design a slot machine one
question i always ask if i'm not
directly told is what return percentage
do you want this game set to
and usually the client will give me a
number
say 93 but sometimes they're not sure
and i will have to
consult with them a little bit and say
well do you want to shear the sheep or
do you want to slaughter the sheep
and if they say we want to slaughter it
then i might say
okay well let's set it to 85 percent no
and if they say no we just want to shear
the sheep and
keep them coming back then i'll say well
how about 90 95
or even 97 and in australia they're all
pretty much set to
between 85 and 92 percent and that's
just awful
i have such pity for the people that
play them because i know what an awful
bet they are because i
i've designed hundreds of these games i
mean
i'm sorry but they're just a lousy bet
although it's the highest house take by
far
if a player only lost 10 of their money
when playing poker machines
it would not be ruinous
[Applause]
but the trouble is if you keep playing
you lose all your money let's say you
put in a hundred dollars
even after wins along the way the
machine is eventually programmed
to return you 90 dollars
you've now got ninety dollars and the
machine is programmed to return you
ninety percent of that
eighty one dollars with eighty one
dollars you'll end up with seventy three
dollars
and so on
until you've lost your last dollar
[Music]
the house will win if i the more i play
over time the less i'll win if i go out
today and play i may win
if i play every day i will lose
there's no chance it's just built that
way
i wouldn't be able to tell you how much
money i've lost
i'd say easily over a hundred thousand
dollars
easily and i did the figure it'd
probably be even bigger
you always think that machine's gonna be
your friend that night and it's gonna
be on your side you can't get away when
you win
even if i had a thousand dollars in a
machine i couldn't take
you know half of it out and go and do
some shopping or anything or put some
petrol in my car
i'd sit there i couldn't get away i'd
sit there and sit there until it was all
gone
i would play for as long as i could
something that really surprised me early
on in my research
is this thing i kept hearing from the
gamblers which was
so strange but sometimes when i win a
jackpot
i get really tense i get frustrated i
get irritated
and i said you know why how do you make
sense of that and they said well
because the real reason that i'm sitting
there is to just keep playing
[Music]
in the 1950s researchers james olds and
peter milner
inserted an electrode into a region of a
rat's brain
that was subsequently dubbed the
pleasure center
rats could self-administer an electrical
current to the region
by pressing a lever
the sensation was so pleasurable they
would endure the pain
of an electrified grid to get their
charge
the rat ignored food and drink and kept
pressing the lever
until it died of exhaustion
until this experiment no one had
imagined that stimulating a part of the
brain
could override the will to live
it would be decades before we understood
the powerful brain chemical
driving this behavior
[Music]
in the early 90s wolfram schultz made
key discoveries about dopamine
don't see much of a difference between
human brains
and animal brains human behavior is
simply the expression of what we need to
do
in order to survive
measuring dopamine in monkeys wolfram's
team
had a revelation
[Music]
we were sitting around the laboratory we
had a little food box in front of
the animal and we showed a little piece
of apple and suddenly the neurons were
going
wild the feel-good chemical dopamine
was signaling a reward to the brain
when the monkey realized the treat was
on its way the dopamine neurons
stopped firing if they knew the reward
was coming
nothing happened but when we gave the
reward suddenly
without any prediction they went
ballistic dopaminers went totally
ballistic
the key is surprise
and just as with skin as rats
unpredictability
with poker machines our dopamine neurons
struggle to predict reward to find the
pattern
to decode the logic of luck
it's in people's you know very nature to
just look for things occurring in a
certain order
i think one of the things that happens
with slot machines it is random and
truly random
but it does appear to be patterns that
show up
i usually tell myself i'm not going to
have any chance of winning until i get
no indians whatsoever
sometimes i just have to wait for 20 30
40 spins and i'll be going like
so there's all this mental stuff going
on like okay so now i've got that
yeah it must be a bit that can't be too
far off when i play a slot machine
i will probably use my human innate
tendency to try to figure out a pattern
there is no pattern in slot machines
anti-doping neurons will be more active
the less of
of a pattern there is all drugs of
addiction
increase the release of dopamine neurons
so if you stimulate the dopamine neurons
you're already halfway
into the direction of addiction
[Music]
some people have a hard time grasping
that a machine could be addictive they
associate addiction with
substances that are inhaled or put into
the body but the fact is most
contemporary neuroscientists
can tell you things like gambling and
these process addictions
are being taken as a purer form of
addiction because they show us a direct
window
into the chemical changes happening in
the brain
[Music]
yeah i had no idea that i could get
hooked to start with when i first
started playing them i just thought it
was a casual thing that you could do or
just go in and play them like i'd
seen them when i was running around as a
little kid and never thought anything of
them and
i don't know why why i liked it
some people will be more prone for
addiction than other people are just
like as there are people with blue eyes
and gray eyes and that's just a natural
variation in the color
of the eyes some individuals may release
more
dopamine or they have more postsynaptic
neurons
are more sensitive to dopamine or they
have a stronger learning mechanism
that could explain why they get addicted
you go back again the next day
because you need that feeling again
i know sometimes i was so desperate to
put that first dollar in
you'd be shaking until you got that
money into there and then it would start
it was the mri that finally allowed us
to look
deep inside the brain to the nucleus
accumbens
where dopamine was produced
we wanted to see the reward system in
humans given that it had been heavily
implicated in animals as being
fundamental for
their kind of addiction-like behavior
[Music]
to see dopamine in action hans and his
team
devised an experiment where cocaine was
given to an addict
where you see red and a little dot of
yellow
that is right on the nucleus accumbens
the dopamine was not just released when
the cocaine
reached the brain we saw the nucleus
accumbens this core reward system
turning on
for anticipation dopamine was stimulated
not just by an unexpected reward but
also
by the anticipation of it the question
arose what other things besides drugs
might turn on the system could we see
the system turn
on in a game of chance
in the next experiment they devised
subjects gambled
on the spinner and none of us
predicted that cocaine addicts
anticipating a cocaine infusion
looked exactly like healthy control
subjects anticipating a monetary win
so anticipation is actually really
fundamental to your experience of
reward what you are doing when you have
a slot machine
is actually kind of repetitively going
through this experience of anticipation
you're like a rat that's sitting there
key pressing to get a little jolt of
electricity
in your reward system
this dopamine that gets released in the
anticipation stage of the game
has been incorporated into the design of
the machines
so when we started to look at the slot
machine games
we really got a bit lucky i think we
were able to get some design documents
the first thing that we saw just floored
us is what people commonly call a near
miss
the jackpot symbol the jackpot symbol
and then the jackpot symbol just above
or below the payline
so you're seeing it the first reel good
you're seeing it on the second reel
good and then there didn't see it on the
third wheel gets those it's like ah
shucks
i'm silly for gambling but i'm not silly
when it comes to certain things like
i see the sequences that come up on
these things all the time
and it's always one missing here one
missing here
one missing where you need it or it's
always like that always
the manufacturers create near misses
up to 12 times more often than it would
happen by chance alone
in other games you couldn't weight
things like that
if you go to a dice game then the dice
has to be fair
if you go to card game you know there
has to be 13 and four suits
who sat around a boardroom table and
said we're going to allow
these things to happen i think that it's
unethical to overly tease the player
with
with near misses and all the games that
i design unless i'm specifically told
not to
have independent reels sometimes i get
asked by a client to just do something
that i think is a little unethical
and i'll try to talk him out of it but
at the end of the day
if the client insists to do something a
certain way
you know i'll do it
my eldest daughter developed
a mental illness she was very very
clever she had fantastic jobs earned big
money used to go overseas a lot
i used to drive my granddaughter to
school
and then coming home i saw one day
outside the hotel
free breakfast so i took to going in
there
and then i saw all the poker machines
and i thought oh yes these are these
things we brought in
banks of them
and i'd sort of look at these things and
these
poor people i thought what are they
doing
why would anyone bother sitting there
inanely at nine in the morning putting
money into these things
it looks like the most tedious thing in
the world
and then this day i thought i'll just
see what it
why they why did they do it and i'd
put my first bit of money in
and it really although it went slowly it
went from there
in the following year my daughter took
her own life
she had discharged herself from hospital
and said she wouldn't do anything to
herself but
i went there and actually yeah and
she was hanging in the garage and she
was dead
and for years i would she would just
it would just appear the image would
just appear
in front of me and i discovered
that the pokies soothed me
comforted soothed
[Music]
it was a place where you could just get
lost in in that world where
nothing else mattered it was like like a
like a hypnotism
10 9 8
and you get down there and after you've
pressed that button a few times
you're there you're in that zone
[Music]
you think perhaps this time
impress perhaps this time press perhaps
this
time press
[Music]
winds come up okay and
that that's not important um you press
it
it is solitary like what i've read of
opium dens where people are lying on
little mattresses
smoking opium and they're alone
they're being soothed and comforted
they're just designed to keep things
flowing
so there'll be a bit of a gallop to the
sound of the reels going
there's a certain timing to the real
spin and how much they bounce
it's all sort of keep this flow going
and being
tied to this thing that maybe not
necessarily alive
but it's quite vibrant
[Music]
one designer said we want to design math
so that you recline on it like
a comfortable couch
another designer told me people want to
be bled slowly
[Music]
designers are designing for the zone
by putting my dollar in those machines
i consented to to playing i didn't
consent
to unlawful hypnotism
[Music]
so
[Music]
and you don't wake up until you look in
your purse
and there's not enough there to get
another dollar
the panic sets in the house payment was
overdue
electricity was going to get cut off and
there was no food for the boys
you try to sneak out without everyone
noticing but you know
the the walk of shame i used to call it
[Music]
and then the next day and the no food
and also the no no tv or anything like
that
i mean that was all in hot you know i
didn't know anything
i've just hurt my family so much
in the financial thing i've got nothing
to leave them
[Music]
i kept hearing this phrase playing to
extinction
and i came to understand that what that
meant was
playing to that point where you've lost
all of your your funds to gamble
and so that's really held up as the
point
where you you want gamblers to reach
i don't remember leaving the venue
that day i remember
driving down the road with the sole
intention
of just killing myself but
i found myself holding up
a store i
used a knife and before i knew it the
police were there
the judge i do remember him saying you
don't look like the criminal type
to me so i had a very lucky escape
the clerk of the court lady
she said to me i know what it's like
said i've got a gambling problem too
there's 200 000 machines in this pokey
nation
and it's the poorest communities who
have the most machines
and lose the most money
so this is one of the fastest growing
parts of australia and it's a fairly
disadvantaged municipality overall
there's not a whole lot of pubs and bars
and all of the
the pubs that do exist have these poker
machines
so we're just coming up to the player
hotel over 50 000
is lost there every day there it is now
every machine in the place makes over
two hundred thousand dollars a year
it makes life very difficult for all the
other local businesses there
every one of them could do with a bit of
that 18 million dollars if it was spent
in their business
we're in sydney's west it's a real
crucible it's a real melting pot
english is not the first language low
socio eco
so many of the people out here struggle
[Music]
our aim is that when the people walk
through the door you know
they walk a little taller they get
called sir they get called madam
and they get treated with dignity
courtesy and respect
the furniture and fittings here at the
club are not what many of the people
could afford in this area
however our aim is that we bring it to
the people it won't cost them anything
to come to our club
and be a part of the five-star offerings
that we do give
both wonderful so we took over the pub
with an idea of what wanted to be
which is a public house you can take the
family take the dog take the kids
everybody's welcome to come in
and it's an extension of the community
the pokey machine is the evil genius or
the person who created the pokey machine
it is hidden away because it's probably
my shame of having them
if you went to a small bar and you said
to them there's a hundred thousand
dollars a year for turning on a switch
it's a tough thing to not want to do the
business
is addicted to poker machines
well gaming represents a significant
amount of revenue
um whilst we are a non-for-profit
organization we still have to run out of
profit
at fairfield rsl about 36 million
dollars
of its 39 million annual turnover
comes from poker machines from my
perspective
the more money that we can generate
through gaming the more money we can put
back into the community
the more money we can put back into the
asset and benefit the members
there's 12 billion in losses the poor
through these machines
annually to the gambling industry and
around half of it
comes from addicted players
[Music]
that money goes to clubs
to pubs to casinos
to companies like woolworths and coles
who together own
fifteen thousand machines but
governments
are the biggest addicts of all relying
on pokey taxes
for five to eight percent of their state
raised revenue
i've got to pay for the schools and
hospitals with the revenue
wherever i get it from gaming is part of
that every uh premier who
initially started out against pokeys bob
carr was one
um is taken aside by treasury and shown
there will be so much more revenue easy
revenue i now declare
it open
this is just political gold that is pain
free
but this is just a ruthless transfer of
wealth from the poorest postcodes
to the gaming industry into the
government
hi where are you peter
[Laughter]
i came into politics in 2004 to a seat
where clubs were well established
before the election i went to a meet the
candidates event
which included representatives of clubs
and hotels and
one came over to me and said you know
we're looking forward to supporting you
handed over an envelope which i
unthinkingly took
yeah i thought it might be literature or
something like that but
it was a check and i gave it back
but it was clear to me that the
connection between clubs and hotels
and politics was quite an intimate one
government and industry run a joint
policy
which takes focus off the machine and
say it's up to the individual
to gamble responsibly
we all believe that we should do more to
help those with a terrible affliction
it damages them and their families and
we understand that
[Music]
so we think that it's a human problem
that needs a human solution
[Music]
i would think i'm the only stupid person
in the world
why can't i stop when i'd be waiting
for the doors to open at nine o'clock in
the morning which is late now
but there were other people there with
me
and they were waiting for the doors to
open too
so this whole discussion of responsible
gambling i mean you
you hear that and if you don't know a
lot about it and what's behind it you
think
great you know who's against
responsibility great
but you have to understand that it's a
concerted public relations campaign
appearing to be responsible for the
customer base
and also putting responsibility on the
customers and off of the products you
know as long as i
put little signs about the the toll-free
numbers to call if you have a problem
then i'm good right and it's all on on
the gamblers
and what isn't then done is any
attention paid
to how the machines work that whole
conversation
can be shut down
there's very strict guidelines around
the way we serve people with
alcohol responsible service of alcohol
you can't serve somebody to the point of
being intoxicated
you have to ask them to leave otherwise
you get a whopping grapevine well
for somebody to be excluded from gaming
from my venue
they have to fill out a form send it
away
with a photo then that photo comes to me
but until that point
they're free to gamble till their hearts
content or their wallets are empty
i'm not irresponsible by nature i went
through
a massive crisis
it's not to try and absolve myself of a
degree of personal responsibility i have
to take that
we all do but those
machines are so powerfully built
that they're built for addiction
the dsm has been the bible of
psychiatric medicine for over 60 years
in its latest edition published after 10
years research
gambling disorder was moved into the
substance abuse chapter
it was the first time in the dsm's
history a non-substance
was listed alongside nicotine heroin
and cocaine
[Music]
there is some evidence that there are
withdrawal symptoms from
gambling disorders similar to what you
see with withdrawal symptoms from some
substance use disorders
often people with gambling disorders
make repeated
but unsuccessful attempts to try to
reduce their gambling
they keep failing at that and they keep
ending up back at the pokey machines
as the weight of evidence was stacking
up a major independent report
recommended changing the machine so that
the maximum bet on a poker machine
should be reduced from ten dollars to
one dollar
the amount of cash players can feed into
machines at any one time
be reduced from ten thousand dollars to
twenty dollars
and with high intensity games people
should pre-commit
to how much money they want to spend
before playing
for the first time in australian history
it looked like the federal government
was going to step in
proposing legislation to minimise poker
machine harm
majority of people in my electorate
wanted some form
of change the new machines were
much better designed they were able to
suck money out of people
much more easily i didn't want to ban
poker machines
but i just didn't want to see people as
social wreckage as a consequence of
their use of poker machines
let's find that middle way but in my
electorate
from the club's point of view and the
hotels
this meant war and they basically
declared war on the reforms
and then they declared war on me
this is about telling mps at the local
level that there is a real
consequence locally of killing your club
clubs bust in about 400 members and
staff to kickstart a series of rallies
targeting marginal seats
of all the lobbying i've seen over 17
years of public life
i think the gaming industries do it best
the clubs have the opportunity to go and
see how other groups
operate similarly group like the
national rifle association in the united
states
the job now is to get all of our clubs
covered in its own australian posters
and coasters thank you very much
ultimately we will spend as much as we
need to
they've cleverly turned it into a debate
about something else
sure enough it came from the pubs and
clubs i guess what surprised me was the
casinos coming out to play
james packer was like silk but he still
had that sting in the tail
which was you know your policy needs to
be my policy
why would you as a government be
proposing a policy without having the
vaguest idea whether it would work
there is a long tradition of politicians
and staffers blending up as
lobbyists on behalf of the gambling
industry these people have enormous
connections into government they know
everyone
casinos pubs and clubs aren't just
lobbying
the labor party and the liberal national
party they are embedded
in the labor party and the liberal
national party for a
proper government and not a couple of
kids like that the hysteria that was
whipped up
just gave you insight into how difficult
it was going to be
to make the change these people who were
making all the money
and alongside that seeing the human
misery that came with it
dug their heels in and said no and then
fought like fury
and unfortunately for the time they
actually won
the federal government buckled and the
reforms collapsed
when you think of the politics behind
protecting this machine
this is a political failure
and the spread of pokies in my view in
australia is really a racket it's a
racket run by people
protecting a predatory addictive product
i'm trying i'm trying to stay
out of the hotels
i can honestly say they've destroyed my
life
and um i just really want it back
you know i think to myself gosh you're
45 you know
20 years of who does that
[Music]
you